it is time for this week's edition of
cbs morning's deals with good
housekeeping today we have three
products that could help keep you safe
and they might just become essentials in
your everyday life to start shopping now
scan the qr code on your screen you see
it there you can also visit cbsdeals.com
rachel rothman is the chief technologist
for good housekeeping institute she and
her team test thousands of products each
year good morning to you what a fun job
a really cool job right super fun i get
to test all the latest and greatest
gadgets and we look at thousands of
products every year in our labs and not
all of them make the grade but these
here
really are phenomenal products make your
life easier and potentially safer i
never would have thought of this do you
know how many times i dropped this and
all the just down down the hatch down
the half it's that black hole in your
car so between your center console and
your car seat um you always drop things
whether it's your phone whether it's a
credit card
lipstick anything and it is so
distracting because you want to go and
reach for it right away and 80 of
accidents happen when someone takes
their eyes off the road for just three
seconds yeah so it's incredibly
dangerous so this this little genius
product right here can help remove that
distraction so you put this right over
the the car the the seat belt yeah
exactly on the catch there and then it's
going to exactly it's going to fit right
in between and it fits all cars so we
tested this on over 30 different
vehicles oh wow and it fit inside of all
of them so it's a really fantastic
product so it'll wind up catching it on
top of it as opposed to it falling down
um we were joking before i love it
because my kids are always throwing
cheerios everywhere and when those smush
on the bottom is really nasty too so not
just for safety but also for convenience
um it's really fantastic so and
cleanliness yes exactly you don't have
to clean out of your seat but it will
smell afterwards yeah
i heard someone doesn't do is that the
good housekeeping experiment but it's
impersonal exactly we'll get this deal
um so this is great it comes with two in
the set for just 15 so it's a really
fantastic deal you should get you know
kids who are driving off to college
right now this is really fantastic you
do not want them diverting their eyes
from the road get this install in every
car that you have so this next product
we've talked about this one before uh
but remind people what it is and as you
demo it i have to warn folks
it gets loud so this is birdie it is a
personal safety alarm and it is so
fantastic because it's this little
product it's also really cute so you're
not embarrassed to take it out with you
um and it'll be a really really loud
alarm so you guys ready for it yeah
cover your ears
there's also a strobe light here so just
get ready for it
and the strobe on the other side
and really that's
you want the loudness because you want
people to pay attention so twofold so
one it can either offer a really
tremendous distraction so if you're
going for a run in the park and you're
not feeling quite safe you pull this and
it's going to immediately draw attention
to where you are and also give you that
split second to potentially run away if
you need to how much are these so these
right here are 18 so it's 40 off so
originally 30 and you could get it for
18 get it for everybody going off to
college if you have a kid going off to
college if you have an elderly parent as
well you may be a little bit nervous
about them off on their own this is
great they just pull it and immediately
it's going to do that really loud siren
you heard it it sounds like a jet taking
off it's really really loud 130 decibels
and because of these bright colors if
it's in the bottom of your purse really
really easy to find 1797 david i want to
bring you in you look like a like the
jeweler down there like a friendly
neighborhood uh
i would buy diamonds
something tells me this is more than
just a necklace yes so it is a beautiful
necklace but above all else this is a
brilliant piece of technology so a
really discreet way that you can send
sos if you are ever in a dangerous
situation so you click on the back twice
you press it twice and a text message is
going to be sent to up to five people
that you've pre-selected to receive this
message or it can also go to 9-1-1
services so you can choose either the up
to five people 9-1-1 or both of them so
a really easy discreet way it's really
harrowing statistic but one in three
women are assaulted
get one for everybody and this is a
hundred and twenty five dollars off
right now so for 125 you're getting this
really beautiful necklace that's going
to offer peace of mind safety security
again people going off to college if you
have somebody who's a new professional
in the city if you have an elderly
parent who's in their home and you know
god forbid something happens they click
it twice and that message is going to go
out immediately and it's a standard
message or you get to customize it it's
a standard message but it's going to
have a link that is going to have your
gps coordinates so that the person can
track you in real time to see where you
can track them too yeah i tried it
yesterday because we we got to play with
these a little bit and my mom was
tracking me all over the city all over
the city exactly yeah there you go only
send it if you're in danger or you want
somebody to be trapped i was testing it
yes yes yes yes this by the way
yellowstone my love language brilliant
yeah oh my god i have it on every single
i am a phone dropper okay yeah my
partner's always like babe how many
times are you going to put in the same
darn place exactly and you never want to
take your eyes off the road so all three
of these products tested by us and we
stand behind them and they're going to
offer that little bit of added safety
convenience and make your life a little
bit easier and all obviously great deals
yeah cool well rachel rothman thank you
so much for presenting all this thank
you so much for having me be sure to
check out the latest issue of good
housekeeping magazine and of course we
partner with all of these companies to
get these incredible deals so to buy
anything you saw today again scan that
qr code on your screen
and don't forget you can also visit
cbsdeals.com we will be right back
there's the code